Louis we have to continue now with the
program that many people may not like
okay you know that I don't do things on
this show for optics I do things for
what I believe is the truth I think you
know that right Louis you've been around
on the show I'm aware of this you know
that I support the broader goals of
black lives matter
wanting real racial justice in the u.s.
wanting to look at disproportionate and
unfair prosecution and incarceration of
black Americans but you also know that I
will call things out when they aren't
quite right this includes me calling out
protest tactics that were
counterproductive to the black lives
matter cause this includes looking more
deeply at broad statements like black
people are more likely to be shot by
police and seeing what the data really
tell us I've been slammed for this I've
been called a white supremacist for this
but I'm not going to as a result of that
do 100 percent gushing commentary about
any particular group when there are
critique critiques to make now I'm gonna
get slammed today too and I'm ready for
it black lives matter put out a letter a
platform effectively and it includes
support of the Israeli BDS movement this
is a platform which in addition to
calling for the boycott divestment and
sanctions of Israel it called Israel an
apartheid state it says that Israel is
committing genocide against the
Palestinians and it said that the fight
of black lives matter for black American
equality in the u.s. is the same as the
fight for Palestinian rights I've told
you before that black lives matter was
hinting at drawing parallels between
their battle and what they see is the
situation in Israel and I've told you it
makes no sense empirically nor from an
optics point of view to be perfectly
honest they have jumped full speed ahead
now I know that when you hear support
BDS and colonialism and the genocide
stop the apartheid it sounds like a lot
wow that's a really overpowering case
what if we break it down into a commits
component parts will you quickly see
that it makes absolutely no sense let's
start with apartheid right black lives
matters platform what for whatever
reason they've decided it points out
that Israel is an apartheid state now of
course apartheid we know Luis is a
policy of segregating and
both economically and politically
oppressing groups of people based on
race or ethnicity typically historically
it is done against the non-white
population South Africa is a common
example of this this is factually untrue
when it comes to its existence in Israel
Israeli citizens have the same rights
regardless of their ethnicity religion
or race period now people will hear me
and they'll say David what about what's
going on in Gaza and the West Bank the
people there have different rules so it
is apartheid there is no doubt that
Palestinian movement between Gaza and
the West Bank and what I guess we would
call sovereign Israel is heavily
regulated but those territories are
governed by the elected Palestinian
Authority and Hamas leaders there is no
comparison to a state of apartheid like
the one in South Africa that is
typically referred to it is a total lack
of credibility to say Oh Israel's an
apartheid state you know very little if
that's what you think yes you just don't
know what apartheid means Israel has had
Palestinian elected officials so please
tell me how that's apartheid please next
genocide oh there's genocide against the
Palestinians the new black lives matter
platform claims there's genocide against
the Palestinians this is also ridiculous
any reasonable assessment would deduce
that there is no such thing as genocide
against Palestinians by Israel genocide
of course the deliberate killing of a
large group of people especially those
of a particular ethnic group or nation
actual genocides are like what the Nazis
did to the Jews what the Turks did to
the Armenians what the Hutus did to the
Tutsis in Rwanda there have been
horrible and tragic deaths in Gaza and
the West Bank
that have resulted from an unfortunate
secure excuse me security state which I
have been very critical of and have
suggested ways to loosen the war in Gaza
has resulted in deaths
it is not genocide we can find
individual terrible acts by individuals
in Israel like in most countries where
you have militaries involved in conflict
but it is not genocide the Palestinian
populations in the West Bank and Gaza
have exploded during the supposed
genocide consistently and significantly
dating back to 1948 in most genocides
the population of the afflicted group is
negatively impacted
by that genocide it doesn't increase
explosively during the Holocaust 78% of
Jews in Europe were killed the Khmer
Rouge killed 25% of its own people in
Iraq 90% of Kurdish villages were once
destroyed on and on and on a couple of
years ago the Palestinian population was
over 4 million data tells us the
Palestinian population is growing faster
than that of sovereign Israel or the non
non Gaza and West Bank areas of Israel
call it what you will by the year 2035
according to the UN the Palestinian
population is expected to increase by 60
percent compared to 40% in Israel that
is not a genocide Lois no just more
people who don't know what genocide
really means and if they are passionate
about genocide yeah sure they can't do
anything about things that happened 20
30 40 50 60 years ago but in Sudan
there's still basically a genocide
happening and this is where the native
black people are being slaughtered
everyone's Muslim here by those who have
come in and taking power and the
government in Khartoum and shouldn't
those who are speaking about genocide
and apartheid in when it comes to Israel
and the BLM movement shouldn't maybe
upset about that I don't get it I will
talk about that in a second last thought
on the genocide thing some people will
hear me say this well the population is
exploded and they will say well David
Israel wants to commit genocide but they
just they've tried but they haven't
killed as many people as they wanted to
kill those are the same people who
talked about the overwhelming and
disproportionate firepower and weaponry
that Israel has you're saying with all
of that weaponry they have been unable
to kill more Palestinians and that has
accidentally led to this population
explosion come on come on
lastly BDS as Lewis is talking about BDS
is be a black lives matter says that BDS
is a movement which shares their goals
of an end to the war against black
people number one most black people in
Israel are not in Gaza or the West Bank
but in Israel proper if you ask them
would you rather be here or in Gaza or
the West Bank figure out what they say
you will be very interested at the
results of what they will tell you and
number two to Lewis's point
talked about BDS people say David why is
BDS inherently anti-semitic well it's
not BDS is not inherently anti-semitic
I've said it many times but it has
become a safe haven for many
anti-semites and if BDS said hey we are
a movement that seeks to use boycott and
divestment to call for change in
countries whose policies we don't like
or are oppressive to groups of people or
whatever and we're going to apply that
tactic everywhere that we see these
problems that would be one thing but no
that's not how BDS work this yeah
BDS has said we want change in Israel to
the extent they believe is warranted and
we could debate that what technique can
we come up with to try to hurt Israel
specifically and that is what Lewis is
getting to and when we talk about the
principles of humanitarian eteri anism
and human rights one of those principles
is the worst first and there is no basis
under which one could argue if we are
just to look at the world and say let's
apply BDS tactics to the worst first
that you would have a group that is
solely focused on Israel absolutely
undeniable there is no question about
this I think this is terrible for optics
people forget that actually many
african-american activists and thinkers
were on the side of what is colloquially
called used to be called a Zionism which
now is like a bad word it used to mean
just a place where Jews can be safe and
not get kicked out of write Edward
wilmut Blyden founder of the 19th
century American pan-african movement
said I have the deepest possible
interest in the current history of the
Jews especially in the marvelous
movement called Zionism w eb Du Bois
founder of the n-double a-c-p said in
1919 the African movement must mean to
us what the Zionist movement means means
to the Jews Marcus Garvey the founder of
the back-to-africa movement said in 1920
when a Jew says we shall have Palestine
and of course that term is being used
because at the time the British Mandate
of Palestine we're not talking about the
same Palestine as Gaza and and West Bank
today when a Jew says we shall have
Palestine the same feeling comes to us
as when we say we shall have Africa and
even Malcolm X declared the year before
he was assassinated that pan-africanism
will do for the people of African
descent all over the world
the same that Zionism is done for the
Jews all over the world not to be clear
I'm not using the sort of caricature
definition of Zionism of settlements and
right-wing governments like Benjamin
Netanyahu
I am unequivocally opposed to those I am
saying Zionism in the the form from the
1920s that is being used here there
should be something like Israel that
exists so to pretend that there is this
natural connection between black lives
matter and anti Israeli movements like
BDS that have cropped up is absolutely
ridiculous now if this is a battle that
black lives matter wants to pick have at
it it will be hugely destructive in a
distraction to their movement which
again the original principles of you can
find no bigger supporter of than me but
it's also going to be harmful in other
ways it's not just going to harm the
movement they probably see this is some
type of outreach thing we're gonna bring
in people from BDS people from BDS are
gonna accept and adopt the BLM movement
but for those who don't really have a
firm understanding of what's happening
over there all of a sudden now people in
BLM like in BDS start throwing around
words like apartheid and genocide
absolutely and all of a sudden you have
a very devoted very anti Israeli new
recruit it escalates the fact free
insanity and you know I know people will
be mad because I shouldn't according to
some I shouldn't even be commenting
about this because I don't have the
right characteristics because I look
white and you know whatever else
whatever rule rules exist for me not
being able to comment on this or at
least be credible tell me specifically
on the facts where you disagree rather
than just I don't have a right to speak
on this issue because of my perceived
identity that's what I'm interested in
this is bad for the BLM movement whose
broader goals I agree with and want to
see succeed